hi this is Mark Hamill and this is the
wired auto complete interview
oh hungry are you to the commissary you
are going
[Applause]
how did Mark Hamill get the role of Luke
it was an audition I went in and I
talked to was Brian De Palma and George
looking for people for Star Wars George
never said a word I came out and I said
who was Brian De Palma's assistant he
said that was George Lucas now I'd seen
American Graffiti but it was just a
general talk you know tell us a little
about yourself it wasn't until later
that I got an audition script
to do a screen test I didn't read the
whole screenplay until I got the part so
I had those 10 12 pages to read I
couldn't make out what what is this is
this like a parody of Flash Gordon who
talks like this it was a lot of
technical jargon it was a scene in the
cockpit with Han Solo I did the screen
test with Harrison and sometimes you
know how you did like oh I really nailed
that one that one I had no clue my agent
said how did it go I said you know I
don't know it went let's see what
happens and you see what happened how
did Mark Hamill get the role of Joker I
just read for it and I had a confidence
that really helped me because there was
this big outcry that Michael Keaton was
going to play Batman oh he's Mr Mom he's
a comedy actor I mean they hadn't even
seen him and they didn't realize how
great he would become but there was
great controversy
so when I went in I thought you think
they're going to hire Luke Skywalker to
play The Joker the fans will lose their
minds I was so sure that I couldn't be
cast I was completely relaxed a lot of
times there's performance anxiety
because you want the part here I knew I
couldn't get the part so who cares and I
drove out of the parking lot thinking
that's the best Joker they'll ever hear
and it's too bad they can't cast me and
as soon as they did cast me that reverse
I was like oh no I can't do this it's
really one of my favorite characters to
play because he's insane and because
he's insane he's never boring it's just
fun to play a character that creates
chaos wherever he goes how long has Mark
Hamill been married oh my gosh I'm not
good at math but we got married in 1978
so blue and 40 something years and it
potentially I think it's going to work
out fingers crossed how to do Mark
Hamill Joker Laugh you know I get asked
to do this I'll be in the grocery store
I'd be Toys R Us do the laptop left well
first of all you have to warm up it's
like a car engine if you just rip it'll
hurt your throat and plus there's no
subtle way to do it so I'm standing in
Toys R Us laughing maniacally and people
are like Cassie me worried looks like
what's that old man doing to that poor
10 year old kid but uh I do get asked to
do it a lot oh I noticed
oh okay we're good there
okay what was Mark Hamill
first job I worked at McDonald's when I
was 15 and a half years old and I was
very proud to make minimum wage
what school did Mark Hamill go to well
my father was in the Navy so we moved
all the time I went to nine schools in
12 years graduating from yokama high in
Japan
what is Mark Hamill's favorite food
uh that's hard to pick I like fruit it's
basic it's healthy and you don't have to
worry about watching your waistline so
much what does Mark Hamill look like now
I look like this shame isn't it
here we have
whom our camel who did Mark Hamill play
in The Flash the trickster
sort of a variation on the Joker which
uh I'm very familiar with as well who
did Mark Hamill voice in Futurama I
think I was the Hanukkah zombie it's
been a while so you might catch me if
I'm off there who was Mark Hamill in The
Little Mermaid well I did two episodes
of the series in one I played Hans
Christian Anderson writing The Little
Mermaid which was interesting because
that was sort of a history lesson and in
the other episode I played Sebastian's
brother which was a lot of fun who did
Mark Hamill play on General Hospital I
played Kent Murray who was the nephew of
Jesse Brewer Emily McLaughlin she was
one of the main characters I wasn't a
real fan of soap operas but everybody
there was so nice and it was a great
education to learn how to find your
light how they hit your marks and I was
on for nine months which was perfect and
I still have great memories of working
there who is Mark Hamill's father my
father is William Thomas Hamill he was a
career naval officer
and I was the middle of seven children
he wanted me to follow his footsteps and
go into the military so sadly I
disappointed him in that regard but
hopefully I've made up for it and by the
way he wasn't that impressed with Star
Wars you know what really impressed him
when I was on The Bob Hope Christmas
special wow now my son has really made
it right here's the is Mark Hamill is
Mark Hamill nice I try to be that's Mark
Hamill Chucky I did do Chucky in a
reboot of Child's Play I'm not Brad
Durer if he's the original Chucky in the
original uh serial Killer's soul is
transplanted into the toy in our version
he was a artificial intelligence where
somebody took off the safety measure so
that he had no restraint and it was a
different approach because he was an
innocent in the beginning and he just
learned the wrong things but I really
enjoyed doing that project is Mark
Hamill Fire Lord ozai yes I am I
remember reading the first group
thinking this thing is going to get
canceled in four episodes because it's
too smart and it said it ran many many
seasons reasons it was really gratifying
to hear that parents like to watch it
with their children because it talked up
to Children rather than talking down to
them and it was a very very smart show
is Mark Hamilton Kingsman yes I did a
small role in Kingsman and it was the
very first one it was nice because it
was just a nice character turn I love
character parts and uh I wasn't
responsible for carrying the movie that
was other people is
well so far but today is Young so let's
wait and see is Mark Hamill in Adventure
Time I Think I did an adventure time but
I can't for the life of you tell you
what character it was once you started
doing animation I don't know I'm sure
over a thousand I don't know Parts the
first one was 92 I guess with Joker but
I remember when the kids were small we'd
be watching Cartoon Network and I go
wait a minute
I think that gangster crab is me and
you'd listen and go yeah it is because
they don't tell you when they're going
to be on and when you do animation it
takes six months for the animation to
come back so there must be hundreds and
hundreds of jobs I did that I've never
seen because it's hard to keep up with
them all okay
and Mark Hamill sing I did a Musical on
Broadway and everybody in it was more
talented musically than I was the way I
described it when I auditioned was look
I can play Finch and I haven't seen in
Business Without Really Trying I'll
never play Billy Bigelow and Carousel
because I just don't have the vocal
chops but it's if it's an acting singing
role that's something I can do but I
haven't done it very often does Mark
Hamill have a Hollywood star you know I
did I got one and I was stunned I mean
what an honor so there you go and now
Carrie Fisher got one very recently and
apparently we're going to be neighbors
so that's nice because she's always fun
to be around was Mark Hamill a figure
skater
you know you're thinking of Scott
Hamilton and we follow each other on
Twitter because he's told stories where
he's got mistaken for me and I've told
stories where they ask me about you know
ice skating so the answer is no I'm not
Ken Markham will speak Japanese I went
to uh 11 to 12th grade at yokama high
school and when I lived there I got
pretty good but the problem is unless
you keep it up every day a lot of it
falls away so I've forgotten more than I
knew if I watch a Japanese television
station or when we've gone back to Japan
things start coming back to me but you
got to keep up with it you can't just
let it uh idle or you forget it forever
just for example I have a dog named Mark
I did an episode of The Big Bang Theory
and the way they brought me into the
show was they had Simon helberg's
character find my lost dog so when he
returned it to me he freaked out he said
oh you're Mark Hamill and I said hey you
doing to this dog I'm holding how are
you doing bark and it was a setup for
Simon did you get jokes about his name
is spark barkhamel I get that question a
lot now because we do have dogs we have
Millie Mabel and Trixie also known as
bat might because of her ears but I
don't have a dog named Bart I should
though
okay
Mark Hamill latest movie The Machine
with Bert Kreischer and it's unlike
anything I've ever done it's uh Bonkers
it's funny it's an action comedy and I
really hope you go see it in theaters
because comedies play so much better
with an audience don't wait two months
and sit and watch it on your couch get
out there laughter is infectious look
all I'm trying to find is one million 11
780 viewers to see it in the theater is
that too much to ask Mark Hamill Yoda
impression here's the problem
when Frank was doing Yoda everybody
started doing Yoda the cameraman the
Caterers wardrobe stand-in stunt doubles
oh hungry are you to the commissary you
are going and Frank eventually had to
say look I'm being influenced by your
impressions and I want to keep it pure
so I could see exactly what he was
talking about we all stopped on a dime
and the rest is history Mark Hamill
hobgoblin it's hard to get Typecast in
animation but I did after the Joker they
wanted me to play nothing but these
maniacal super villains it was hard to
try and make sure you stayed away from
the Joker with hobgoblin I I put him
down lower and made him a little more
Sinister in that way but it's really fun
doing animation because the definition
of the character actor is an actor who
disappears into their role they don't
see the actor they see the character
well animation does that for you they
don't see the actor so you can play all
these parts that you would never get on
camera you know I never got to do
dialects on camera I mean I think by law
only Meryl Streep is allowed to do
dialects so I got to play Australian and
Italian and all these different
characters that I love animation and the
animated voice Community is so wonderful
they're so welcoming and so talented
these these people I'm telling you I
went to sessions so entertained that I
thought you know in any other
circumstances they could have charged me
a cover charge for being at that four
hour session that's so much fun it is to
do animation Mark Hamill video gaming
roles I played video games when my kids
were small but when they outgrew them I
didn't continue on so I don't really
play video games the most memorable
recently were the Arkham Asylum games
with Kevin as my Batman as he always was
people will come up to me and say when
you get to level three if you do I said
you know I hate this first year bubble I
have no idea what you're talking about
because no I don't play them you don't
have to play them to voice them mark
Samuel Harrison before impression all I
can say is I did him once on I think it
was Seth Meyers the next time I saw him
he said hey
I don't sound anything like that I said
yeah I know you don't sound anything
like that but his voice is so minimal it
draws you into what he's saying like you
know he says it in such a soft-spoken
manner that alone I think is a part of
what makes him so riveting as an actor
but I'm lucky to have worked with him
were you surprised by any questions yeah
I guess a few I mean you play video
games I hate to have to admit in front
of everyone no I don't play video games
without you out of your mind you should
have told the Dorothy Hamill story oh
well I got pulled over one time for
going over the speed limit the guy said
license and registration I gave it to
him now that we Dorothy Hamill was on
the cover either time or Newsweek I
can't remember which and it happened to
be on the passenger side I was driving
alone and the officer when he said
Dorothy Hamill is that is any relation I
said yeah she's my sister and I get it
all the time and so sick of hearing
about her skating career and he goes oh
could you get me her autograph and I
said do you want her autograph and he
gave me his information I probably
shouldn't admit this he'd probably come
find me and arrest me but when I got
home I signed the magazine cover best
wishes officer whatever your name is
XOXO Dorothy Hamill because we do spell
it the same way and he ripped up the
ticket and saved myself what like forty
dollars now I hope the statute of
limitations has run out otherwise I'm in
big trouble
[Music]